hey guys feet here today I'm going to do
a new video related to season three and
a theory that comes from secret history
of Twin Peaks yesterday I talked about
the secret history and some of the big
ideas themes and characters that are
probably important when it comes to
season three today I want to look at
something more specific and point out
that there are about a million of these
little gems in the book I found this
theory on reddit so I have no claim to
come up with it originally but I found
interesting and I think you will too
this is your spoiler warning if you're
not caught up with twin peak season 3
through part 8 you'll want to stop
watching now there is information from
the secret history of Twin Peaks but
it's only a small detail so it wouldn't
likely spoil the entire book for you I
would also like to remind you like I
said in my last video I think that the
secret history is a must read for
everyone who is a Twin Peaks fan I think
you should check out that video and if
you haven't seen how awesome the book
actually is check out the link in the
description of this video so in part 8
we saw the Trinity test at White Sands
in an awesome sequence which seems to
have added some supernatural
consequences towards a Twin Peaks
universe the Trinity test was of course
the culmination of the Manhattan Project
and the test was the first atomic bomb
detonation that mankind managed to pull
off it happened in the desert of New
Mexico and was conducted by the United
States Army that's basically the real
history and a quick rundown and in part
8 of Twin Peaks the return we saw what
appeared to be the introduction of the
character Bob into the world but of
course he may have existed much earlier
than 1945 and we'll talk more about that
later
and my other episode 8 videos explain my
thoughts on this event and much of what
I've read since putting together my
recap and review last week it's pretty
much on the same basic page man
successfully detonated the bomb and the
large spirits got the call the dark
forces were Unleashed
and the giant or the firemen over at the
White Lodge issues
arms beyond the bob orb that we saw and
a large amount of eggs that came out of
the spew put forth by the mother figure
known as the experiment we also saw a
bunch of these woodsman characters
milling around outside of a convenience
store we had seen a lone woodsman two
different times in season three once in
a jail cell near bill Hastings and again
in the coroner's office where major
breaks his body was held in both times
this was in Buckhorn South Dakota in
part eight we saw several of them
arrived after evil Cooper gets shot by
ray as they're escaping Yankton federal
prison which is also in South Dakota at
the end of part eight one of these guys
takes center stage in New Mexico in the
year 1956 he sort of flies in and I mean
like literally flies in from the sky
scare some people on the road and then
takes over a radio station where he puts
the listeners to sleep by repeating a
hypnotic sort of mantra or chant or
whatever you want to call it this was an
exciting occurrence because when we
check their credits we learned that he
was named the woodsman fans recognized
this right away and it seemed to line up
with the popular fan theory that the man
in the jail cell might have been one of
the characters named the woodsman that
we saw in the meeting room above the
convenience store from fire walk with me
the missing pieces only it wasn't either
of the actors that had played the
woodsman or the woodsman number two and
again it wasn't the same actor that we
had seen in the jail cell and Buckhorn
this is not to mention the other
difference that all the woodsman we've
seen in season three have been covered
in what looked like oil but it's
probably or possibly some kind of suit
so we found out that this guy was a
woodsman but we kind of got blurred on
other popular theories and the question
remains who are these woodsman well a
redditor named link TM had an idea that
was interesting which connects back to
an event that we learned about from the
secret history of Twin Peaks this is
something that happened way back in
nineteen
- back in the old days before twin
peaks' was an actual incorporated city
and the two rival logging operations the
Packers and the Martel's which we know
from characters in season one and two
were locked in a battle for dominance of
the region through this there was a
competition going on and long story
short the river ended up jammed with a
bunch of you know fallen trees that they
were transporting by water and for seven
miles there was this massive log jam
this went on for a couple weeks and
basically it got out of hand to where no
one knew how to resolve the problem On
February 24th that came to be known as
the night of the burning River a fire
started on the on you know these logs in
the river and it spread to land in that
catastrophic kind of event six guys lost
their life immediately and two others
died after the fact from complications
based on their injuries so that gives us
a number of eight eight guys who could
definitely be considered woodsmen but
eight guys we also don't know much more
about died on that night February 24th
is an interesting date in Twin Peaks
history because in 1989 on February 24th
Laura Palmer was killed and her body
showed up wrapped in plastic and was
found by Pete Martel so late TM puts it
out there that maybe these eight guys
who died in this fire in 1902 are the
same woodsmen we see now he broke down
some of the images of these guys from
the scene where the nuclear explosion
happened to Trinity and he says that he
counts no more than eight individuals in
any of the scenes it's a very difficult
thing to do so that's definitely not
exact I know some people say that they
counted more when I look at it I can't
tell beyond the fact that I know that
into the clearer scenes there are eight
of them but in almost none of them can
you see all their faces or anything like
that so without some real serious
in-depth analysis
wouldn't be able to say without a doubt
that there's only eight of them there
but it is an interesting idea and it's
one of those facts that slipped into the
secret history of Twin Peaks that you
kind of wonder why is it there if not
for some sort of reveal like this later
on down the road so that is the theory
the theory is that perhaps these guys
that died back in 1902
in a fire that was started by what most
people assumed was dry lightning from
the passing storm but there were also
reports that it was like columns of fire
or descending from the sky so nobody
really knows exactly how this started
it's like the most likely thing is that
lightning started which you know
electricity lightning that's all
interesting in our story but then you
know there's other reports that say that
it could have been columns of fire
falling from the sky so it's an
interesting thing I don't say that I
know for sure I did jump on it right
away because I'd remember reading about
this fire there's actually a picture of
the aftermath in the book as well so let
me know what you guys think do you think
that this has something to do with the
woodsman we've been seeing do you have
another idea that makes more sense what
do you think that would mean for the
rest of the story and Bob in general you
know like these guys clearly to me seem
to be helping Bob in aiding at least if
that wasn't Bob in the egg you know
people some people think it is some
people think it wasn't but one way or
another they were definitely aiding in
that creature making its way to a host
so although we haven't seen much from
them as far as talking before their
influence is more than just to be around
lurking they're doing nothing I mean as
soon as evil Cooper got shot they
descended on the scene so they
definitely have some involvement with
people and what do you think this means
for I mean that was a very popular
theory that one of those woodsmen was
the log lady's husband Sam you know
Sampson Sam Lanterman who also died in
the fire outside of the Twin Peaks area
that kind of pulls that apart or it asks
the question what's the difference
between these woodsmen that
covered with the black substance and the
woodsman that were in the meeting above
the convenience store there's a lot to
think about and some interesting stuff
so let me know what you think please
like the video and subscribe to my
channel I got plenty more twin peak
stuff coming out and we got part 9
coming up so let's keep the discussion a
lot thanks for watching be talking to
you soon